a visionary a revolutionary the son of a
nation for the nation not just lyrics to
his song 34 years after the
assassination of burkina faso's
president
he's still revered by millions of people
across french-speaking africa
1983 he was described as a feminist and
environmentalist than a 33 year old
soldier he was ahead of his time he
turned his back on international aid
money and loans from organizations like
the world bank instead favoring
self-sufficiency and calling for a more
equal relationship with france the
country's former colonial power on the
15th of october 1987 sankara was killed
by an armed group along with 12
officials his closest friend and former
colleague bless konpauer took power now
he and 13 others are due to go on trial
charged with murdering sankara this
trial is important for the manifestation
of the truth and that's why it's really
important that the blessed campaign be
honest one even if it's the only time in
your life
you must stand and tell the truth
bless
ousted in 2014 following a popular
uprising that brought an end to his 27
year rule he lives in exile in
neighboring ivory coast and has refused
to take part in the trial his supporters
see it as a political witch hunt
i don't understand that politicians that
once worked with him are now so bitter
and desperately seeking revenge
porkina is suffering enough already this
needs to stop
according to official government
documents sankara died a natural death
but in 2015 authorities exhumed his
remains from a grave an autopsy revealed
his body was riddled with bullets
in 2017 french president emmanuel macron
agreed to release secret files on
sankara's death that led to the opening
of the trial there is a desire for
justice not just in burkina faso but
throughout french-speaking west africa
because those behind
the assassination sought to
silence sankara in his ideals but it had
the reverse effect millions of people
across french-speaking west africa see
in sankara a symbol of resistance
against the powerful he's become a hero
and an icon celebrated in arts culture
and politics
many of those involved in the recent
cohen malian one in guinea last
september have referenced sankara's
leadership as an inspiration
these are some of his last words in
public
we need to accept we are africans it's
the only way to live with dignity
sankara says adding do you want to see
corrupt government officials or soldiers
then we will get rid of them this may
cost me my life but we are here to dare
shortly after this speech
sankara was shot dead nicholas hawk al
jazeera